And now, I'd like to introduce you to our speakers today,
Professor Rita Popat and Professor Kristin Sainani.
So, Professor Rita Popat is
a clinical associate professor in the Department of Health Research and Policy,
and the co-director of the master's program in
Clinical Research in Epidemiology at Stanford University.
She has a Ph.D. in epidemiology and also holds
master's degrees in Biostatistics and Physical Therapy.
Rita has taught several methodology and
data analysis courses at Stanford for more than a decade,
and has received several Excellence in Teaching and Mentoring Awards from
the Graduate Program in Epidemiology and at the Stanford Medical School.
Dr. Popat specializes in teaching and mentoring medical and allied health professionals.
She has a strong interest in developing curriculum
and implementing new instruction models and recently,
developed a blended course in Epidemiology
and Biostatistics for Stanford medical students.
She is also interested in neurodegenerative diseases and studies the role of
genetic and environmental factors in Parkinson's disease and lateral sclerosis.
c So, Professor Kristin Sainani is an associate professor here at Stanford University.
She also co-directs Stanford's Ph.D. program in Epidemiology and Clinical Research.
Kristin teaches statistics and writing and performs research in sports medicine.
She also writes about statistics and science for a range of different audiences.
Professor Sainani has received several teaching awards,
including Stanford's 2018 Biosciences Award for Excellence in Graduate Teaching.
She has authored the health column body news for Allure magazine for a decade,
and she is also the statistical  editor for the journal,
Physical Medicine and Rehabilitation,
and she authors a statistics column,
Statistically Speaking for this Journal.
She teaches two popular Massive Open Online courses,
including Statistics in Medicine on OpenEdX,
and Writing in the Sciences on OpenEdX and Coursera.
And now, I'd like to turn the floor over to Kristin and Rita.
Thank you. Well, welcome everyone.
Good to have you all.
what I'm hoping to do in
the next few minutes today is to give you an idea of the kind of
content and material you're likely to
see in the certificate program in Clinical Research and Epidemiology.
So, just briefly, when we talk about clinical research and epi,
what we're often interested in is
an understanding or evaluating a relationship between an exposure and an outcome.
And the exposure could be anything,
it could be a genetic factor,
a non genetic factor, a drug,
or any sort of lifestyle factor.
Here are three examples that just hit the news last week.
I researched this in preparation for today's webinar.
Here's the first one.
Does alcohol consumption during breastfeeding,
is that associated with poor cognitive outcomes in children?
Another example that we saw recently and last week,
was actually researchers here at Stanford,
where they examined whether a Acetyl-L-Carnitine,
I'm just going to call it LAC,
whether these levels
and this is a chemical, by the way,
which we all produce,
naturally in the body,
and it's important for brain function.
and they wanted to see if this was associated with
increased risk of major depressive disorder,
which I will just refer to as depression.
And here's a third example.
This is sort of a stem cell therapy example,
where do induced pluripotent stem cells,
can they help
cure, so to speak,
or reduce the symptoms,
alleviate the symptoms in Parkinson's disease?
As you can see here,
we've got three examples of three very different kinds of exposures.
We've got alcohol consumption, which is, of course,
a lifestyle factor,
it is an exogenous sort of risk factor.
We've got a naturally
endogenous chemical like the LAC,
and then we've got sort of stem cell therapy.
Let's elaborate a little bit.
Let's look at this example with LAC levels in MDD.
As I said, these are researchers from Stanford.
The study was published in the Proceedings of National Academy of Sciences.
This got picked up,
got a lot of news attention,
you can see there's one article talking about whether low LAC levels is a new biomarker.
With this new interest in precision medicine and
the role of biomarkers in
predicting who's at risk for certain diseases.
This is sort of an interesting angle to look at this particular chemical.
Then you've got a blood test that could be used for treatment.
So, you've got a prediction
potential as well as a treatment potential.
Very briefly, what the researchers did is they looked at LAC levels in
the plasma among a group of patients who had MDD and a group that didn't.
The blue dots are the ones who don't have major depressive disorders and
the red dots stand for people who actually do have major depressive disorder.
And you can see that LAC levels are
lower in those with MDD compared to those who don't have it.
And we won't to get into the statistics,
but you can see it's a highly statistically significant p-value of .0002.
You might say, "Oh, wow. "
Should you be compelled?
Should we all go out and start taking the supplement which,
by the way, is available,
in health food stores?
Would you be recommending this to your relatives or friends who may have MDD?
Hm.
I hope you all will be skeptical because
before we see and decide whether we should start taking this
supplement, we want to ask the question,
and this is what we hope to train everybody who's in our program to first ask the question,
how was this association between LAC levels and MDD evaluated?
We logically think of this as three steps.
The first step is a research methodology.
Then we go to step two,
which is how was the analysis done?
And finally, how do we make
our interpretation based on the results and how the study was conducted?
So, let me elaborate a little bit on step one, since my colleague,
Dr. Sainani, will elaborate on step two,
which is the statistical analysis.
So, in step one,
when we talk about research methodology,
simply put, we're asking three basic things.
How was the study done?
What was the study design?
Who was in the study?
What was the study population?
And finally, what measurements were made?
I want you to think about,
if you were interested in this relationship between LAC levels and MDD,
what do you think might be an appropriate way to actually design the study?
I'm going to leave out the clinical trial because
we're not gonna start randomizing people.
We first wanna see evidence from observational studies.
Let me help you out.
I'm sure you all
can probably come up with this design.
Let's say you're the investigator.
You're going to get a group of people who
don't have MDD now.
We won't get into inclusion,
exclusion criteria, but you will choose your cohort of people.
You will then measure their LAC levels at baseline,
and then you will follow them forward in time,
and then you'll evaluate who develops MDD versus not.
Sorry guys, I know the guys lying flat are not meant to be dead.
It's just to
illustrate the two different groups,
a group that developed MDD and a group that didn't.
By the way, a fancy word
for this design is a prospective cohort study.
We like these studies
and you can see why because causality's in the right direction.
What I mean by that is that the exposure that is LAC levels comes first,
followed by the outcome MDD.
If we do find an association,
at least the design helps us explore whether this is causal in nature.
As I mentioned, that's a fancy term for this design.
Now here's another way to do it and maybe some of you came up with this design.
So, you're still the investigator,
but now you start with a group of people who have MDD,
and a group of people who don't have MDD.
And then you go back and then you try to determine
their LAC levels either taken at that cross-section in time,
or maybe from samples that were stored previously.
Now let me ask you this,
among these two designs--
By the way, this is the case control study.
Of these two designs,
which one do you think is the stronger one to,
bear more credibility that there is a causal link?
I think we would all say the prospective cohort study.
What if I told you what these researchers did was actually a case control study?
You see before you get all starry-eyed
and blown away by the statistics and the p-value,
you really have to evaluate how the study was done.
Now, I'm not trying to say that the researchers say that there is a causal link.
I want to be mindful that they were correct in the way they interpreted the data.
But for most of us,
when we look at the literature,
we just focus on the statistical piece and the P values,
and less so on what the methods were that generated these results.
And in my courses,
I focus a lot on this methodology piece
because we can see that certain study designs lend
themselves better to understanding causal associations.
We also want to ask other questions.
So this is about measurements.
How was Major Depressive Disorder ascertained?
Were reliable and valid methods used?
Was it used in a standardized manner in the entire study sample?
How were the LAC level measures?
Were the assays reliable?
How about validity?
Does a LAC level taken at one cross-section of time,
is that truly reflective of one's,
exposure to these LAC levels over time?
You see it raises a ton of questions which we need to keep in
mind in order to correctly interpret the study findings,
and then because it's an observational study,
we worry about other confounders as well.
What we have to really be able to separate is causation versus association.
We can't see non causal explanations that can
generate spurious associations which were then exposure and outcome.
In this course we also spend time talking about sources of study biases that can
produce these furious associations when actually there's
nothing going on between the exposure and the outcome.
We first have to actually rule out all non-causal explanations,
and then ask the question
is there evidence to support a causal association between the exposure and outcome?
And two quick points.
Just because you absorb a statistically or
clinically significant effect doesn't mean there is a real effect.
And the converse is also true.
Just because you fail to observe a statistically or a clinically significant effect,
it doesn't mean that a real effect is absent.
The study methodology could be so flawed that you actually fail to pick up the signal.
A flawed study methodology can also do,
what we see above,
where it can produce a spurious effect.
We kind of have to be detectives, clinical research detectives,
and as detectives we do is
we try to figure out how much was a study finding influenced by bias.
And what's bias?
It's any deviation of truth beyond chance error.
These are systematic errors by the investigators in sampling,
collecting, or interpreting data.
This is how we culminate the course where
we've learnt about the methodology and I give students papers to read, they read it.
We look at the study findings.
If we believe that the study has some truth in it,
then we say the study has internal validity,
and then we move on and we ask,
could this be useful in clinical practice or in
designing the next research question?
On the other hand, if we determine that there's too much bias in this study
and that it really affects the validity
and we are skeptical whether there's truth true in this study,
we stop right there.
But in the previous scenario,
if the study does have some truth,
then you can ask about generalizability or external validity.
And this is where we ask the question,
can what we found in our sample be applicable to the study population beyond that?
and where we want to apply these findings do.
But if we messed up the way we sampled and the way we actually
study then came up with the study sample that generated the results,
then while the study may be valid,
it may not be generalizable to the population
beyond that was included in that particular study.
So, true or false? I get this question a lot because not everybody is going to
be doing perspective data collection and be designing these studies
and you may be working with existing data.
Here's the question I get.
We don't need to worry about study design and measurements because we're
using an existing database or a datasource
and information has already been collected.
We just need to understand how to do the data analysis.
Of course, I'm setting you up because this is false,
and I hope we've given you,
I've been able to give you a small example to show you why it's not.
Even if it's just secondary data that you're using,
you still within that need to ask yourself about measurements,
about whether it's the right database to be
answering a particular exposure outcome relationship,
and whether you can even get to answering the question about causation.
In a nutshell,
when we want to examine an exposure outcome relationship,
step one is research methodology.
The statistics is very important too because
Epidemiology and Clinical Research is a quantitative field,
so you have the methods and you need the statistics and
analytic approaches to be able to
quantify the relationship between the exposure and outcome.
But the methodology informs the statistics and in this series,
in this certificate program too,
you will learn about statistical approaches that can actually help you
account for some of the weaknesses in the study methodology,
things like confounding and control for those types of variables.
Finally, we need both the methodology and
the analysis to help us with the interpretation.
So clinical research and epidemiology, for whom?
Who should be studying this?
If any of you are interested in research or studies that involve human subjects,
either active data collection or recorded data,
this might be the one for you.
What skills will you learn?
These are just some that
I've put here.
I'm sure there are others and Dr. Sainani can chime in,
but here are some of the skills that you hope students,
not just in our program,
but in our certificate program will learn.
How to critically evaluate a published paper?
How do you conduct peer review of a research manuscript or grant?
Some of you may be serving in these roles and it's
a huge contribution to the scientific community to know how to critically
do a peer review of a manuscript or a grant,
which is all done on a volunteer basis by the way.
How to develop a study protocol for an observational study or a clinical trial?
For those of you who are in the trenches,
who are helping PIs design studies, conduct studies,
our courses will help you develop these type of study protocols to assist the PI
or perhaps you are the PI who's developing the protocol.
To help you develop analytic approach appropriate for the proposed study design.
To conduct data analysis.
with the help of the courses that my colleague here Dr. Sainani teaches,
and how to interpret results.
So very briefly, in our Masters program where we
have three core courses in the methodology series,
you've seen that the numbers here are HRP 225, 226, 251.
The description is given below.
In the certificate program,
we are asking students to
you're required to take two of them.
That's 225 and 251.
So, what do these courses cover?
HRP 225, which is design and conduct of clinical and epidemiology research studies,
we cover descriptive epidemiology,
sampling methods, reliability and validity of measurements,
analytic study designs,
their strengths and limitations,
cohort case-control, cross-sectional studies.
We talk about measures of association,
things that you might be familiar with,
like odds ratios, risk ratios,
hazard ratios, sample size estimation.
How do you power your studies?
How many people do you need to study a relationship?
Sources of bias, confounding.
We talk about interactions.
We talk about causal inference.
We do a systematic critique as a culmination having learned all of these concepts
and we also touch upon diagnostic tests and screening.
The spring quarter class,
which is called HRP 251,
is focused on clinical trials, exclusively.
So, you must have an intervention that you can randomize.
Now we also touch upon early phase trials,
so let me just go through some of the topics that we cover in this course.
We've got design issues,
how to think about outcomes and how to select them,
surrogate versus hard clinical endpoints.
We discuss phase one, phase two studies,
these are your early phase study designs,
phase three study design,
the large efficacy trials.
We talk about recruitment and adherence.
Sample size and power.
Since we are at Stanford,
and we have people who have developed amazing adaptive design.
You will hear about adaptive designs in designing your clinical trials.
How to handle missing data,
data analysis, and interim monitoring,
both from a statistical perspective,
as well as the data monitoring committee perspective.
So with that,
I hope I've
piqued your interest and your appetite for
clinical research in Epi
and now, to my wonderful colleague Dr. Sainani.
Thanks, Dr. Popat. That was actually a great lead in,
to my presentation
because my courses focus primarily on the statistics,
but it's so important to keep the statistics in context.
How were the data collected?
Where did those data come from?
You can't interpret that,
the statistics in a vacuum.
I teach a three
course sequence in biostatistics
for the Master's program in Epidemiology and Clinical Research at Stanford.
You see the course numbers up there.
For the certificate program,
you would take the first two of those courses, which is
my introductory and my intermediate biostatistics courses.
I'll just start by talking a little bit about,
something that Dr. Popat
alluded to which is that you have to be skeptical of the published literature.
And we have, as many of you are probably aware,
a reproducibility crisis in science
and this has to do with many facets as
Dr. Popat alluded to,
research design, how you design the studies is a key part of that.
I'm going to focus, of course, more on the statistics,
but it's all important.
This is one of my favorite studies that came out in 2005 by John Ioannidis, who is,
actually now a faculty member in the Division of Epidemiology at Stanford
and he published a paper called My Most Published Research Findings are False.
And he was pointing out that a lot of the
findings in the literature actually are false positives,
spurious associations that can arise either because you do a study with bias,
or because of the study design,
or because of the statistics,
or all three of those.
If you like late-night television as I do,
you may have caught
there was a John Oliver piece,
a couple of years back
just dealing with
talking about this whole reproducibility crisis.
So you see this even in the media
and the popular media right now
there's been a couple of high-profile cases,
I'll just point out here.
So, there is a case with a scientist,
a high-profile scientist at Cornell who does food science.
His research had been highly cited,
talked about in the media,
and his research has come under scrutiny for a number of reasons
one of which is sloppy data handling, something we're gonna try to
talk about with you in my classes,
just try to help you to
to not have sloppy data handling.
Another issue is
a lot of his research findings
seem to have come out of what's called P hacking.
What that means is
if you push your data in enough ways,
if you kind of try all possible associations with all the variables in your data set,
you are going to find some spurious associations.
Some things that
achieve statistical significance, P is less than .05.
But those are almost certainly going to be false positives
and that's one of the things we talk about in my classes
is trying to avoid P hacking.
I'll just put up a few more.
This was an article that was in 538.com.
This was actually
something I was involved in.
There was a statistical method introduced into
the sports science literature that causes high false positives.
Some of you may have read in New York Times or other media outlets about
some famous research on power poses in psychology
that's been largely discredited.
Again, a lot of these things have to do with poor study design,
as well as poorly done statistics.
What I try to do in my classes
is to teach you how to do reproducible research
and to do good statistics.
I blame some of the issues
with poor statistics in the literature on how we teach statistics.
And I'm not saying that all statistical teaching is bad.
I think there are some great statistical teaching that goes on out there,
but I notice that a lot of statistical teachings seems to fall in one or two camps.
The first approach is a perfectly valid method.
This is how I was trained,
but it's highly theoretical
with a lot of math.
A lot of calculus,
linear algebra, and proofs.
Not so much practical training on how to deal with data.
I love this kind of stuff.
I like to do proofs,
one of those equations up there is from one of my papers from this year,
but this approach is not appropriate for every audience.
People who are doing applied sciences in psychology, education, medicine,
may not need to know all of the math,
and may not need to work out all the calculus
if their goal is really just to analyze your data properly.
If you try to teach it in this way
and it's not a match with the audience,
sometimes what ends up happening, I've noticed,
is that we swing to the other extreme.
Instead of teaching all the math,
we suddenly teach none of the math
and you end up with more of a cookbook approach
and that's the approach that I find really problematic.
Because when you end up taking out all of the math,
it becomes more of
I just have some data,
I want to know how to get it in the statistical analysis program and get something out,
click the right buttons and get results.
And I think this is a problematic way to teach statistics and also to do statistics.
It leads to some of the reproducibility issues that I was just talking about
because if you are just kind of throwing your data into a statistical black box,
not really understanding what's happening in that box,
and what the results mean that come out,
unfortunately, this leads to all sorts of problems.
And one of the problems is that
if you are kind of fuzzy on what exactly is coming out of that black box,
it's too easy to cherry-pick out of the results that come out.
And I'm not saying scientists do this intentionally,
I think it's mostly unintentional,
but if you're kind of fuzzy on what those results mean,
it's very easy to just kind of select the ones that
seem to support the story that you want to tell
and then get excited about that story and publish a story that is misleading.
I'll just give you one example of this.
This is something I was looking at recently.
This is from a published paper
and they were looking at glucosamine,
which is a supplement that sometimes people take for knee osteoarthritis,
which is pain and stiffness that you get in your knee as you grow older.
And they randomly assigned- it was a randomized trial-
it was a smaller randomized trial,
I think it was about 50 people and they randomly
assigned half to take a glucosamine supplement daily,
and half to take a placebo pill.
Now, if you looked at the published study,
there was no graphical representations of the data.
They simply put all the data in a table and I was looking
carefully at that table and noticed something and so
I do quite a bit of statistical sleuthing.
As Rita said, we have to kind of be a detective and
I really enjoy statistical sleuthing.
I actually just pulled the data out of the table and graphed it myself.
There were two primary outcomes for this study.
The pain that you have in your knees and your disease severity,
sort of an overall disease severity.
I'm going to show you my graphs.
This is the data that I just took out the tables and I simply graphed it.
And what you're seeing here is the graph for pain.
The Y axis is the percent change since baseline,
you want it to go down because you want pain to get better.
And the X axis is time in weeks.
This was a 24 week study.
The blue line is the treatment group,
the red line is the placebo group.
And you do not need to know any calculus,
or have a degree in math or statistics I think
to interpret this graph correctly.
I think we can all look at that and agree that there
was maybe some small decrease in both groups.
If anything, the placebo group went down more in pain than the treatment group.
And actually, those two lines are
within the statistical margin of error of each other.
Really there's no difference showing up between those two groups.
The authors of the paper got that right as I'll show you in a minute.
They got the right conclusion with pain.
Where things went wrong is when it came to disease severity.
Some kind of scale people filled
out to say how bad their disease is flaring up.
Again, we want it to be lower.
Take a second here and look at that graph,
same general graphic, treatment is in blue,
placebo is in red,
and take a second and see what conclusions you think you would draw from that graphic.
I think all of us kind of looking at that would probably
agree that it doesn't look like there's much difference between treatment and placebo.
In fact, they ended up after 24 weeks,
at almost the same level of disease severity.
In fact, you can see there's some drop in disease severity.
And this indicates that there is some kind of placebo effect going on.
So, it's a subjective measure.
People take a pill
and when you take a pill sometimes,
you feel better just from the placebo effect.
That seems to be what we're seeing here.
The only real difference that you can see between
the two groups is probably just due to chance fluctuation.
They have a slightly different trajectory.
For some reason,
it might be just chance,
the treatment group went up a little before it went down and then kind of was levelled,
whereas the placebo group went down a little and then up and then went down,
but they ended up in the same place.
So, it might surprise you to hear that what I would consider a null result,
in the paper, the authors put a positive spin on it.
And in fact, this is comes right out the abstract.
They say, these results suggest that the consumption of glucosamine,
the supplement, for 12 weeks or longer has a positive effect on osteoarthritis score.
Osteoarthritis score is that disease severity score I was just showing you.
Now, they've got it right in pain.
In contrast, it does not reduce pain.
So, let's look at that graphic again.
How in the world is that a positive effect?
The placebo group and the treatment group basically did the same.
It doesn't seem to be any benefit from
treatment and I think it's easy to see in the graphic.
So, what happened here?
I think this is one of those cases where the authors took their data up,
they stuck it in a computer program,
they were happy to get out some result and in the midst of all those results,
there were a few significant P value.
And I'll tell you there was,
a significant P value.
The drop from 4 weeks to 12 weeks in
the treatment group happened to be a significant decline.
But guess what? The drop in the placebo group from
12 weeks to 24 weeks was also a significant decline.
They didn't make a story out of that,
but there was a true decline here.
There was an actual placebo effect.
People did feel a little better, subjectively.
There was also a significant P value,
there's a technique called repeated measures in Nova.
And when you plug those data into that,
you do get a significant P value.
That significant P value though just tells you that the trajectory,
that the lines, the path those two groups took was a little bit different,
as you can see visually here.
It does not tell you however that the treatment group beat the placebo group.
Unfortunately, if you're not quite sure what these statistical methods are doing,
you'll see those significant P values as you get excited,
you make a story that's false.
I'm going to teach you in my courses some principles of effective statistics.
One of the most important things
is that you can't do statistics well without
understanding the basics of probability and statistical inference.
You can't do statistics without any math.
Now, that doesn't mean we have to swing to the extreme
of putting in a ton of calculus and linear algebra.
I believe that most of what you need to know in
statistics can be taught with subtraction, multiplication, division.
You may also need to be familiar with like decimals and fractions,
but that's the level of math that's required in my classes.
You also need to use common sense around numbers.
I'm going try to teach you what is statistical inference, what is probability,
and a good strong understanding of those
but you don't need the fancy math necessarily for that.
And one of the techniques that I use for teaching is computer simulation.
We will do a lot of computer simulation.
I'll just give you an example of that.
There's a lot of problems that can be solved mathematically,
but can also be solved in a computer.
And one of the classic probability problems that you're going to see in
any sort of probability 101 course is called the perfect problem.
And it goes something like this,
some of you may have heard of it before.
Imagine you have a class of 30 students.
What's the probability that in a class of 30 students,
that two people, at least two people are going to share the same birthday?
They were both born on August seventh.
And instinctively, most of us
think that that probability is gonna be pretty small, right?
There's thirty people and there's 365 different birthdays.
Um, surprisingly though, that probability is quite high.
In a class of 30,
there's actually a 70 percent probability that two people will share a birthday.
You can solve that problem mathematically,
and for those of you who are interested I will
solve it mathematically in my course for you.
But you can also solve that problem with
computer simulation and I think the computer simulation is really intuitive.
And what you do, we have great computing power these days so,
you can do this on a laptop in a second,
you actually have the computer randomly sample 30 birthdays out of all possible 365,
366 if you include leap years birthdays,
and you have a computer do that arbitrarily large number of times.
So hundred thousand times,
a computer can do this in a second.
You look then at all of those samples and you
look at the birthdays and see how many of those samples was there a match?
You had the computer count up and all those different 30 classrooms,
out of 100,000 times, how many times did you get a match?
And that would give you the exact same answer as if you solve it mathematically.
We'll do a lot of computer simulation to help
motivate what's happening under the hood in statistics.
Another principle of effective statistics
is you need to understand your data.
We don't just stuff things into
the statistical black box and press the button to do a t-test.
Before you do that,
90 percent of your data analysis is actually not doing the t-test,
or the linear regression, or getting P values.
It's actually drawing pictures with your data,
understanding how much missing data you have,
understanding where your data came from,
making sure that you don't have errors in your data,
and really just getting a sense of what's going on in
your data before you ever run a formal statistical test.
I've already talked about drawing lots of picture of your data.
You need to use common sense.
Always consider the totality of the evidence,
don't just cherry pick.
And we're also going to talk a lot about keeping an accurate record
in code of everything you do to the data in all the analyses you do.
I mentioned earlier the case of the scientists
at Cornell whose work has come under fire.
A lot of the problems have to do with not keeping an accurate record,
not being able to produce data sets or
code that back up an analysis in a published paper.
I teach again two courses in the certificate program.
In the fall, you'll take HRP 259,
that's my introductory course.
We will spend quite a bit of time on the theory of probability and statistical inference.
A lot of that, as I've already mentioned,
we will do with computer simulation and there will be some math of course.
You have a choice,
you can work in either R or SAS.
We use the free version of SAS,
SAS University edition.
R is also free,
and you don't have to do a
course in both of those.
You're just going to pick one of those and I will teach you how to code.
There is no prerequisite.
It's fine if you have never coded in either one of those before.
If you want to learn both, you're welcome to try to learn both.
Wwe will also do the practical side of data analysis.
How to think about,
look at, and describe data?
How to actually get your data into R or SAS, clean it,
manipulate the data,
count up the missing data,
and then how to actually analyze it?
We will talk about how to choose the right statistical test,
how to run a regression,
how to interpret the results from those statistical tests properly.
We'll talk a lot about common statistical pitfalls that underlie
a lot of the reproducible ability crisis in the literature.
And I really enjoy being a statistical sleuth,
so I will teach you how to be a statistical sleuth.
My winter quarter course is a mix of theory and practice again.
We will continue to analyze data in R.
SAS is getting a little bit more complicated in our coding.
I will talk about some more advanced regression techniques and things like
how to deal with correlated observations,
and some more advanced techniques like
principal components analysis and propensity scores.
And again, we will fundamentally make sure that we're not hitting
statistical pitfalls and also will learn how to be a statistical sleuth.
And that ends my portion so
I'm going to pass it back.
Great, thank you so much Kristin Rita for this really informative presentation.
And I hope all of us
who are here with us today can really walk away feeling
more confident and knowledgeable about both of your work,
and as well as some of the
topics that are related to Epidemiology and Clinical Research.
Now let's move to the Q and A portion of this webinar.
So, the first question that we have
for the both of you really is
more about
the prerequisite.
So, not in terms of courses.
Do I need to take
STATS101 or
maybe a senior level stats course back in undergrad,
but more so about kind of knowledge
that you guys think would be most appropriate before coming into this program,
so that they can get the most out of these courses.
If you can just talk a little bit more about prerequisites and knowledge,
that would be great.
Sure, I can jump in.
So there are new prerequisites in terms of
you do not have to have had a previous STATs course,
and you do not have to have experience coding in RSS,
we will teach you all that.
As I alluded to you,
you have to be comfortable with basic math, decimals, fractions,
nothing too complicated, and it's helpful I think to have some context.
If you are somebody who is doing
research and you are familiar with the medical literature,
that doesn't mean you have to be an expert on it,
but you maybe read a medical paper or
are involved in research,
that context does provide the basis and the motivation to take our courses.
For the methodology courses,
there are no prerequisites.
I think having some familiarity with having at
least read an occasional scientific paper is helpful
and if you've taken a STATS course,
of course that's helpful in terms of content.
We are within the School of Medicine.
Our examples tend to be very clinically focused,
but we have students all across campus who take up classes,
so we have students from engineering, or
some other discipline who may not know enough about medicine.
And when we first bring up examples, they are like,
oh my gosh, do I need to know what Parkinson's disease is?
No, you don't.
What's the wiki for?
Wikipedia. No, you don't need to know.
The principles apply broadly across and you don't
need to be an expert in biology and neuroscience or anything,
you can come from
any background and benefit from this material and
be able to get back value from the courses.
Great. Well, I hope
that was really helpful for all of you.
So the second question that we have is,
based on your knowledge,
what is approximately the time commitment that's related to some of these courses?
Because a lot of our audiences are working professionals or are full time students,
how much time do you think they would have to
dedicate to successfully complete the courses and the workload?
Okay, well there's always going to be a range.
Yes
By the way,
for the students or
the participants who are asking these questions, you are not alone.
In fact, in our master's program,
a substantial number of students are actually fellows and residents or
medical students who were juggling several responsibilities.
What we've done is,
so in terms of in class time, for example,
225 and 251, we meet twice a week so that's three hours
of in class participation or watching the video.
Of course, there's going to be homework assignments,
so I would say in addition to three class time hours, maybe another three.
Again, this is the range,
it could go from one to maybe five hours depending on how familiar
you are and how in-depth you also want to go.
I would agree there.
It's five to six hours might be per class is probably a good target.
You should know that we both read and I designed all of our courses around
a physician audience of working physicians who have to go to clinics several days a week.
We have designed our courses to be very comprehensive but also efficient
to help to save you time.
For my courses, all of the lectures are online,
it's about two hours of lectures including the lectures on programming each week.
And then of course,
there's some reading that you could do alongside.
Sometimes you may need to watch a video twice,
if it's a more complicated probability question.
It might be three hours,
and then I also have class time where we spend doing solving problems.
So again, it might be about three hours of lecture and
the class exercises and then however much you want to prepare beyond that,
I have weekly homework.
There are some online quizzes,
so you might be about three hours,
I would say would be a good target but there will be a range depending on
your comfort level with math and familiarity with these topics.
Great. Also the question that we have moving forward and I think this was actually
a really popular question from
our participants is a lot of them are actually thinking about
maybe using this as a stepping stone into a PhD program.
Can you further elaborate on
how some of those content in the course could
potentially help them pursue a PhD in that field,
and would you recommend this course
to students
who are taking it for that purpose?
Sudents in our PhD program take some of our courses- these same courses.
And let's say that you know you want to do a PhD and sometimes people pursue
a Master's first but let's say you don't want to necessarily do a full masters,
first you could get a lot of the beginning content through these four courses.
That would be a good foundation to want to
know if you really want to continue into a full PhD in this area,
and also to have a good foundation to do a PhD absolutely.
Yeah, I think it depends on your background.
I'm assuming that if you want to pursue a PhD in this field or something that would be
related to that would require these skills in which case as Dr. Sainani said,
to think, is just the subject material really is of interest to me?
Do I get excited by it?
Would it be a wonderful opportunity,
and then of course to also test the waters and see
how comfortable you are with
the material and whether you can really challenge yourself
within the domains of statistics and
methodology as you apply for a PhD program.
Great. So on that note,
we also have a few students or participants here who
are asking about academic help,
throughout this process.
As most of these courses are going to be offered online,
will they receive
the same level of academic support from the professors,
from the teaching team, and how will that process be  carried out?
Yeah, we will treat you as any other student in our courses.
You are considered a student of course as we see you on our same enrolment list
and the additional thing we're going to
do for the online courses because of the issue of
being remote and some of the in-class activities that we do
are very hands on I think in both my courses and Dr. Popat' courses.
We will have a TA who is the liaison to the remote students
to help make sure that those activities that you're trying on your own were normally,
we walk around the classroom and sort of look into your code and-
oh, you're missing a semicolon there-
That there's a similar experience for
the remote students by having a TA who is dedicated to that.
Yeah, definitely. I think we are committed to supporting the students who
are doing a certificate program in the same way that
we're committed to our students who are on campus.
We will make sure that there are TAs who can provide the help and assistance.
And will office hours also be available for students who are remote?
That's a great question. Yeah, I have a normal Monday office hour and
we may have to figure out how that exactly works as we won't be in real time with
the students and we will have another office hour option for that.
Also the office hours are taped.
if you wanted. Sometimes students just come to get help on their homework.
and then often if you have a question,
somebody else who actually comes to the office will answer the question.
Some of my on-campus students actually don't come to the office
however watch the video and then they can get their questions answered.
So, I don't tape my office hours.
but we do make sure that
a T.A.
is able to respond to your questions and
we would be available as well.
Great. And now it's time for
a lot of people's favorite question
about the outcomes.
What am I going to get out of this program?
What type of career paths and
employment options would be available to me?
Based on your experience of
teaching this course here on campus in the classroom
what type of career routes and paths
do students usually take after completing these classes?
I can take a couple of examples.
I'm talking to now necessarily not physicians.
Actually we didn't get a chance to see the poll results from
the first polls so I don't know what backgrounds our participants come from
but I assume this question is from those
who are not clinicians or clinicians in the making.
and I think there are actually two or three that come to mind.
Two or three groups.
One being
if you are involved,
if you're a research coordinator,
and you want to do actually more,
not just recruit patients and help with
the day to day functions of a clinic or a lab
then having these skills you can be more involved
and assist the PI
in actually helping them develop protocols as well as
setting up databases and even helping with statistical analysis,
and to look at sort of preliminary data and so on.
That's one area.
Another area is if you come from the writing world,
Medical Science journals
this would of course be immensely helpful.
The third group is if you are obviously working at a biotech company.
Gilead, GenenTech,
these pharmaceutical companies often have epidemiologists
who are on their teams.
And often what the epidemiologists have to do is to actually see what's out there,
what's been published, what's the disease burden,
and they have to actually do a systematic review of
the existing evidence and these skills will help you,
add to the kinds of things that you couldn't
do in these roles.
Yeah. I will just add that
I think the skills that we teach are largely foundational skills.
I mean, they're in a particular area about medicine but
data science is a huge field right now.
Being able to analyze data in ourselves and
understanding the implications of where the data come from,
that's a transferable skill
across a lot of fields right now.
Right. And if I may add Dr. Sainani just reminded me.
Let's say you're someone who just comes from a bio stats background.
You did a Masters in Bio Stats.
Often the statistics just sits in a silo
learning about the methodology and how to actually approach the data analysis,
what we constantly tell our students is that the statistical program is
just a tool and we don't want people just using that- using it as a black box.
So, how to think about analyzing and thinking about
the approach that's informed by what the methodology was and what the measurements are,
are the skills that we do teach.
Actually Dr. Sainani
and I have been teaching this for over a decade and so I pretty
much know what she covers and she knows what I cover
and it's a very nice complimentary
sort of teaching sort of partnership.
Yeah, great.
And this question is specifically,
for Dr. Sainani.
We have a participant that asked about,
how rigorous really is the statistics portion of this program?
Are we going to be dealing some of the more advanced topics
including kind of amputation hidden mark,
half models and such?
I would say it's
very rigorous in the sense
that I want to start in the foundations and I want you
to do data analysis properly so you're going to document your code,
you're going to understand the models.
My HRP 259 course largely focuses on that,
so we don't necessarily get beyond regression analysis.
We focus on doing statistics right.
And I actually think that once you have that,
the particular statistical test that you're going to run that's easy to look up online,
and figure out how to do it in ourselves.
I think the foundational stuff is much more important.
In my second
course, we cover some more advanced topics.
We don't cover Monte Carlo simulation
I cover a little bit about imputation.
We talk about missing-data imputation.
Dr. Popat also talks about that in her courses.
We don't get into it in a very deep way
but I would say the courses are
are quite rigorous and that you are expected to not just be able to
do those and implement those but really
understand the foundations that build up to those.
Yeah. I think we do have courses in place.
I teach one in the spring but it's not part of the certificate program.
I think you need to,
as Dr. Sainani says,
once you have a good foundation,
the statistical techniques you have to be aware are going to keep developing.
In fact we have to constantly
educate ourselves about what's the new method of doing,
you know, X, Y, or Z.
And once we know the basics and you look up the papers and
you read them and then you see the code is available
Right. I teach a lot
through computer simulation and I'll tell you
if a new statistical method I've got to learn.
I find that, "Oh, I've got to run that on my data."
First thing I do is pop it into the computer and run a simulation so I have a sense of.
I have some data which I understand the generation of the data.
I put into the statistical method then I can understand the pluses and
minuses of that method so that the particular methods to me in,
in a way are less important than knowing how to assess
them and how to understand what's going in and out of those methods.
And also you need to know
Sorry, this is a pet peeve of mine.
Because there'll be a new thing like instrumental variables or even
propensity score matching and
these techniques are all sophisticated and fancy but sometimes it's
overkill data really
And sometimes it's something recycled that you actually you can do in
a simpler way and then just trying to make it fancy.
Great. So, now I know we're getting a little bit close
to twelve o'clock so we have time for two last questions.
The second to last question that I have here is really about
since this course is focused more on clinical
medicine just in a more traditional sense,
will any of the courses cover alternative medicine
in clinical research or integrative medicine?
So, again, our course is not specific that it has to be clinical or public health.
I think the principles broadly apply.
If you're interested in community research,
if you're interested in alternative medicine,
integrative medicine, great. I love it.
But you can use the tools to evaluate these
alternative therapies in a rigorous way
so that
we need to see more rigorous research in that domain.
We are examples you certainly see them.
We certainly have a broad range of students on campus. Dr. Popat.
have some from engineering,
from psychology, from education.
For them the specific examples may not be
exactly in their domain but that's okay, they're applicable across.
Great. So, last question that we have today.
I'm sorry but we still have 50 or so questions here from all
of our participants I would love to address but we only have time for
for one last one here.
Last question that
came from participants is that
what type of resources would you recommend them in exploring
between now and perhaps September so
that they can prepare for the content for the course?
If there are any resources that you would
recommend like books or websites or courses,
more intro level courses that they can
seek out outside of Stanford?
Perhaps your mook.
Yeah, I mean I have a mook.
That's a good introduction.
Then you could check some of that out as an introduction.
Don't feel like you need to do a bunch of homework before you come to us.
We start from step one.
If you want to download R or
SAS University edition and play with both of those and figure out which one you prefer
or maybe do a little research about
different areas of research.
People will use SAS and some people will use R so
figure out what people around you are using so you can make that choice.
That might be one of the things to do for homework.
Actually that's a great
suggestion and I am more comfortable with SAS.
That's what I intend to use.
And in my courses we
we won't be using that much for methods but
SAS university edition has wonderful tutorials and video
recordings of how to download it, how to use it.
Right.
So it's a good idea to play around.
And again
we have a good colleague right now who is currently in the moment,
taping some introduction videos on how to download R and SAS.
So don't feel like you have to do that but
if you want to be prepared and
and do a little bit of that ahead time it'll just make your first week easy.
Perfect. Thank you so much again Rita and Kristin
for answering all the questions from our participants
and for really great and informative Q&A session.
We are at top of the hour right now.
It's about a minute until 12:00.
Unfortunately, we won't have time for any additional questions.
But if you'd like to learn more about this program,
please don't hesitate to reach out to us directly.
Our contact information is available on our website
as listed on the slide that you see in front of you.
And also make sure to check your inbox for the webinar recording within the next week.
And you'll also have an opportunity to reach out directly to us as well.
Thank you again
Dr. Popat and Dr. Sainani for joining us today,
and we wish all of you the best
as you pursue your education goals and academic endeavors.
Thank you for joining us.